in London's Theatreland the lights are
illuminated but the doors are firmly
shut and cinemas advertising springtime
blockbuster movies a taking zero at the
box office for the first time in history
when stay-at-home measures were
introduced the effect on arts culture
and entertainment industries across the
world was instant and devastating a
sector worth 13 billion dollars to the
UK economy alone now entirely shut down
with many music concerts and theater
productions cancelled for good it's the
smaller independent venues that will
suffer enormous Lee we went dark on the
16th of March and because we are
receiving theatre most of our income
virtually all of our income comes from
our box office so the minute we can't
show a production and have the audience
coming in obviously income and then cash
flow for the organization becomes
incredibly critical the film sector is
also hurting the Cannes Film Festival
vital to the survival of world cinema is
postponed but hopes to be resurrected
later in the year the building that
usually hosts film stars in the film
market is now hosting the homeless
around 70 men and women who would
otherwise have nowhere to go during the
lockdown in France hundreds of films
have halted production or delayed
release putting many self-employed
people immediately out of work instead
some set builders technicians and
engineers are offering their skills to
help build makeshift hospitals for the
overstretched
NHS while the Arts Council is hoping
their new emergency fund will help keep
institutions afloat we've already put
together a package of emergency funds
from the Arts Council of a hundred and
sixty million pounds and but even with
their government interventions that have
already been announced we know that
that's not going to be enough perhaps
once quarantine is over there'll be more
appetite for the cultural communal
experience than ever before right now
streaming platforms like Netflix and
Apple TV are coming into their own but
national theaters royal ballets and
classical orchestras are also putting
their content online for free finding an
entirely new audience
some artists are still drawing a small
crowd in Spain a singer performs nightly
from her balcony to local residents in
Barcelona Italy
scenes from classic films are projected
onto buildings something for people to
share in isolation charlie Angela al
Jazeera southern England